is pulling at the door there yeah oh
well so we got a hold of Jerry's cakes
and torrents and they brought us a cake
Eric can you bring it in it's a nice
cake all the big German kids yeah okay
you got this cake that oh nice and the
owner wanted to come in to to say hello
look at that cake now it feels like it's
great thank you for coming in and Jerry
and Jerry made this that's the amazing
part of this I meant on the left over
there there wow you know I gotta give
this crew credit they normally don't do
much work but man did you guys outdo
yourself with all the surprises so I got
Al Mike I got two of the greatest ever
I got Jerry and Al Michaels all looking
looking for a golf course right here
this early you'd normally be tramping
around bel-air Country Club today I'm
just getting in oh okay I'm on the other
side of the clock right now have you
guys played golf before we have yeah
because Jerry's really good I think yeah
I saw him playing cards one day and at
Bel Air I liked I just love when Jerry's
on the range he takes an 8-iron and
there's a flag out there and like 115
balls are within three feet of the flag
boom well one of the finest golfers I've
ever played about you know basketball
was your life but or did you take the
same kind of competitiveness to golf
Jerry could you turn it on and off like
that well you know I think you know when
you first started anything Dan it's it's
such a shock to pick up something that
all of a sudden you can see yourself
getting better at and I've always felt
that golf might be the most addictive
game there is and particularly for young
kids once you start learning how to hit
the ball correctly it seems like you're
in the slit your every day goes by
you're trying to do something different
and once you get to a certain point
in your time when your game gets pretty
good then you get really confident about
but it's the most frustrating game and I
like to be frustrated okay I really do
usually you do well that's a good game
then because they never mastered it no
no one mastered that game Wow I believe
Jerry shot 29 on the back nine one time
correct 28 thought there was a penalty
stroke in there somewhere
no I didn't think so I Pauline are you
shocked me here so you got a cake Dan
Patrick show cake you you got Jerry West
to come in Fritzi got Jerry West to come
in Wow we called mr. West who's been
nothing but nice to us and he said get
up in this early in the morning and
bring a cake in no problem yeah 14 let
me just tell you on short notice he's
getting ready to get on a plane to San
Francisco his wife Karen was kind enough
to help us track him down he couldn't
have been nice as we all knew he would
be and I'm very short notice he changed
his plans made arrangers to be here for
you on the 10th anniversary one of your
idols Jerry West and I said this to
these guys that every time I see I see
my dad
we thank my dad you know he loved the
way you played so the last time you're
here I was pretty emotional well thank
you you know it's one of the thing I
think strange things about sports is
that it's just amazing to me how people
become so attracted with all sports
today this country has changed greatly
because of sports
I watched today and I watch the all the
talk that goes on in this country and
other derogatory things that men said
and I always have felt that particularly
in basketball it's probably the greatest
leveling of society coming together my
teammates I was a lot of times in my
life I was predominately or just a
couple of white players in team but I
walked away from this game having
greater respect for my black teammates
and maybe anyone and to this day every
time I see some of these incredible
players play it thrills me to see
where this game has come and our
greatest stars are revered today by
everyone in this country throughout the
world and in basketball they're almost
always always black and it thrills me to
see that happen I want to thank both you
guys for coming in do you mean the world
to me you really do and I if you want to
have some cake Jerry you look like
you're still in playing shape there my
thanks too to Jerry West and Al Michaels
thank you again for stopping by to
celebrate our 10 year anniversary
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience